[Music]
a hot debate is brewing in alaska these
days over what is worth more the bold in
the ground the gold in the water a
record 60 million salmon surged through
the state's bristol bay last month some
30 million were caught and will feed
half of the world's demand but near the
headwaters of bristol bay the canadian
mining company northern dynasty has
found what they think could be the
biggest gold and copper mine in the
world and if they dig it the side
effects could be toxic that mine's
development stalled under president
obama but president trump's
administration has given the
controversial project new life and as
part of my cnn series the wonder list i
learned how many forms of salmon love
and life might be affected including the
big furry residents of katmai national
park
[Music]
this is not supposed to happen
we are supposed to hunker down and
admire distant grizzlies through long
lenses
but these two mamas and their bunch of
kids
they didn't get that memo
holy [ __ ]
well that was unbelievable
we were in the middle of a bear parade
well we were we stood our ground
we we
made our focus in one spot and they came
to us yeah you guys okay having fun
[Music]
brad believes this is safe in part
because this is one of the rare spots in
alaska where humans carry cameras
instead of guns
but here's that one place where bears
respect
people because people respect bears
there was a time when the state of
alaska thought that if they killed the
bears there would be more fish for the
people but brad tells me the salmon runs
weren't nearly as healthy
when this guy poops in the woods as
bears do he's spreading marine nutrients
into these valleys they are stewards of
an environment where everything is
connected by salmon i'm scared every
year are they going to come back and
every year so far they show up like
miracles and i say oh thank you and
everybody's happy and the bears are
happy and the gulls and the eagles and
the foxes
and the wolves um they all they all cash
in
and at the top of that food chain are
all the people who cash in on the salmon
and what really worries them these days
is what lies beneath the ground
above bristol
it's this this red spot right here turns
out that red spot
marks a monster fortune
northern dynasty believes there are a
hundred million ounces of gold
in them thar hills oh and 80 billion
pounds
of copper
this space this little chunk of real
estate could be worth
half a trillion dollars
over the next century or so
but in addition to gold and copper this
ground also holds millions of tons of
sulfur mixed with air and water sulfur
turns to acid
critics of the pebble mine worry that
acid could get into the watershed
destroying one of the last great salmon
runs left on the planet
the developers of pebble mine insist
that they can pull that golden copper
out safely the idea that the mine will
destroy the fishery is incorrect they
insist but fishermen and
conservationists and biologists most
native tribes disagree they fought this
project for more than a decade
but then president trump won and one of
his epa administrators scott pruitt's
first act is opening the door settling
lawsuits and allowing the development of
the mine to move forward so the fishing
folk it's interesting you've got
fishing republicans versus mining
republicans fighting over what do we
want to risk because you know salmon
used to run all up and down the east
coast but we damned so many rivers that
the last great spot where they just keep
coming back in droves is so well managed
is there and a lot of people say that's
not worth gambling wow it really is one
of the most beautiful places in the
world alaska yeah yeah thinking that too
and the bears i never thought i'd get
that close
well i saw the guy chewing away the
bears where were you i was right behind
him oh okay okay using him
i was like were you in the car yeah you
have guns on them though right no they
didn't they didn't get a flare
and this is the one spot where there are
no hunting they've opened up hunting for
predators bears and wolves elsewhere in
alaska but this one spot
they get to coexist when i when i was in
alaska you know they had they looked
like they had a gun for just in case
yeah
um
thank
little plug here the wunderlist season
three back on cnn next